[Aplausos]
[Música]
estonia es un país vale lo sé puede que
parezca una obviedad pero es que seguro
que muchos de los que estáis viendo este
vídeo no sabíais que existe un país que
se llama estonia y es una pena porque si
hay un país que debería ser un modelo a
seguir ese es estonia de entrada es el
primer estado en reconocer internet como
un derecho básico para todos sus
ciudadanos pero hoy vamos a centrarnos
en otro aspecto muy destacable de este
país atentos
la historia tiene el sistema de
impuestos más competitivo de toda la
ocde ella sé lo que estaréis pensando
impuestos competitivo estonia debe de
ser un trabajo mejor aún debe ser el
hollywood de los paraísos fiscales a su
lado islas cayman parecer a suecia pues
no tranquilos por ejemplo el impuesto de
sociedades en estonia está en el 20 por
ciento el irpf también está en un 20 por
ciento está claro que no son impuestos
tremendamente altos pero tampoco es un
islas mauricio ni un leaf stain y una
andorra ni siquiera una suiza sin
embargo pese a no tener impuestos
especialmente bajos y estonia ha atraído
a un montón de empresas y es la cuna de
startups como skype transfer wise o bolt
[Música]
de hecho tienen una política muy
original para atraer a empresas y
talento la residencia electrónica lo
contamos con más detalle en un vídeo que
os dejo en la descripción para que os
hagáis una idea ese vídeo es de los
primeros vídeos que hicimos en visual
política cuando todavía tenía pelo por
aquel entonces sólo unos pocos habían
solicitado esa residencia electrónica
pues bien ahora hay más de 70.000
ciberciudadanos vamos casi casi la
población de andorra tal vez nos parezca
un número muy grande pero recordad que
la población de estonia son solamente un
millón de habitantes y diréis vale
fenomenal historia puede ser un pequeño
silicon valley pero y qué tal se vive
por ahí hasta qué punto no están
sacrificando los servicios públicos a
favor del crecimiento económico tiene un
estado del bienestar y la respuesta es
que sí
[Música]
al igual que casi todos los países
europeos
estonia también tiene un estado del
bienestar con salidad pública educación
pública y carreteras y no sólo eso su
sistema educativo es uno de los mejores
del mundo según el informe pisa--
estonia es el quinto país con la mejor
educación superando incluso a finlandia
además servicios como el transporte
público salen a coste cero para el
ciudadano es decir que si estáis
paseando por las calles de tallinn o de
tartu podéis subirnos al tranvía sin
tener que comprar un billete tal cual
como lo oís y ya se lo que estaréis
pensando muchos seguro que estonia se
puede permitir todo esto porque son
super ricos de verdad pueden seguir su
modelo en los países más pobres pues lo
cierto es que estonia está lejos de ser
un país de millonarios al contrario
hasta los años 90 formaban parte de la
unión soviética hace solo 30 años este
país no sólo estaba atrasado sino que
además vivía bajo la continua amenaza de
una invasión rusa vamos que tenían todas
las papeletas para terminar como una
ucrania en miniatura sin embargo hoy en
día generan noticias como esta
y la historia se convierte en el único
país del mundo con presidente y primera
ministra mujeres así que la pregunta que
hoy nos hacemos es por qué decimos que
estonia tiene el sistema fiscal más
eficiente del mundo aunque no tenga
impuestos especialmente bajos cómo
funciona un país así que elecciones
puedo llegar estonia a otros países hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
el salto del tigre nuestra historia
comienza en el año 1996 muchos de
vosotros ya habíais nacido alguno de
vosotros incluso estaría bailando el
wanna be de las spice girls que por
aquel entonces arrasaba en el mundo
desarrollado
en ese momento pocos habrían dado un
céntimo por historia
[Música]
en lo que a economía respecta estaba un
nivel parecido al de argelia o colombia
al menos en lo que a pib percápita en
paridad con el poder adquisitivo
respecto a todo esto hay que sumarle el
desempleo que no dejaba de crecer y la
'fuga de cerebros' pensando bien estonia
se independizó de la unión soviética en
1991 en pocos años privatizaron casi
todas las empresas públicas y
liberalizar los precios
esto significa montones de personas en
el paro y una subida de precios
importante y por supuesto por aquel
entonces hablar de internet o de nuevas
tecnologías era como hablar de papel
higiénico en una pandemia y entonces es
cuando llegó este señor con pajarita que
veis en pantalla
tomás henri quilmes
en aquella época este señor era el
embajador de estonia en los eeuu y dijo
lo siguiente
algo que ha marcado mi forma de pensar
respecto a estonia la idea de que
deberíamos tener a nuestros jóvenes
trabajando con ordenadores tomás hendrik
ilves así es como nació la llamada
estrategia del salto del tigre y
básicamente internet era una revolución
en ciernes aún era un territorio nuevo y
todos los paises empezaban a explorar
sus posibilidades en otras palabras que
un país tan joven como estonia tenía una
ventana de oportunidad para liderar esta
revolución y vaya si lo hicieron
desde que el señor ilves llegó de
estados unidos con su pajarita y su idea
revolucionaria el gobierno priorizó los
ordenadores e internet por encima de
todas las cosas en pocos años todos los
colegios estonios tenían ordenadores
desde el gobierno se organizaron toda
clase de campañas para educar a los
ciudadanos en el uso de nuevas
tecnologías y en el año 2005
estonia fue el primer país del mundo en
organizar elecciones con voto
electrónico en el año 2000 el parlamento
estonio reconoció el acceso a internet
como derecho humano y todas estas
políticas dieron resultados inmediatos
en la primera generación de estudiantes
que habían estudiado con ordenadores
surgió una primera ola de startups made
in stone ya alguno de vosotros se
acuerda del famoso caza por si no os
acordáis se trata de uno de los primeros
programas para compartir archivos p2p
suena otro programa llamado skype pues
también nació en estonia por estos años
pero esperad un momento porque esta fue
la primera época dorada de estonia y
duró bastante poco porque si pensáis que
la historia de este país ha sido siempre
un campo de rosas os equivocáis
bruce es acusada de lanzar una
ciberguerra para desestabilizar estonia
habéis oído bien estonia ha sido pionera
en muchas cosas entre otras en ser
víctima de la primera ciberguerra de la
historia el primer ataque cibernético
hacia un estado de la historia se
produjo aquí en el año 2007 pensar que
por aquel entonces prácticamente toda la
administración de estonia ya estaba
digitalizada así que durante varios días
el país entero se colapso podríamos
hablar largo y tendido sobre por qué se
produjo este ataque pero lo vamos a
dejar para otro vídeo porque el mayor
problema de estonia llegó un par de años
más tarde más concretamente con la gran
crisis financiera del 2009 si hay un
país golpeado por esta crisis
ese fue estonia
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea ese año el
pib de eeuu que hay un 25 por cien en
españa a un 38 por ciento y acordaos del
impacto que tuvo esa caída por algo lo
llamamos la gran crisis financiera si no
pues yo que se lo llamaríamos la mini
crisis financiera o la crisis cita
financiera pues bien en estonia la caída
del pib fue de un 14,4 por ciento es
decir que el país entero se fue a freír
churros y en ese momento de crisis
existencial el gobierno se viene un
dilema subimos los impuestos dejamos que
nos rescaten o aplicamos políticas de
austeridad extremas es decir austeridad
con mayúsculas pues eso es exactamente
lo que ocurrió de un año para otro el
gobierno de estonia hizo una pequeña
bajada de impuestos y una bajada salvaje
de gasto público para que os hagáis una
idea despidieron al 40% de los
funcionarios y diréis funciona esta
estrategia pues podéis juzgarlo por
vosotros mismos
aquí podéis ver el pib per cápita en
paridad con el poder adquisitivo de
estonia si os dais cuenta en sólo 30
años estonia ya ha superado a grecia y
portugal y está acercando a posiciones
con españa todo esto es un auténtico
milagro si veis dónde estaba cada uno en
los años 90 a día de hoy el paro en
estonia no llega ni al 6% y todo esto
sumando los efectos de la pandemia y la
pregunta es pero como lo han hecho cuál
es la fórmula mágica de verdad basta con
tecnología y mucho internet para tener
un país así pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver el sistema fiscal más competitivo
del mundo ya se lo que se estaría
preguntando todos a estas alturas que
queremos decir cuando hablamos de un
sistema fiscal eficiente de entrada
hablamos de un ranking elaborado por la
tax foundation como todos los rankings
es muy discutible y no hay que tomarlo
como las sagradas escrituras pero es
importante que entendamos que
competitivo no significa necesariamente
bajo en muchos casos no se trata de
cuántos impuestos pagamos sino de cómo
así que hacen que la economía estonia
sea tan competitiva lo primero es lo
simple que es su sistema fiscal
podemos resumir casi todos los impuestos
de estonia con un número el 20 20 por
ciento de impuesto de la renta 20 de iva
y 20% de impuesto de sociedades- simple
y sencillo en el caso del impuesto de la
renta existen varias excepciones para
las rentas más bajas por ejemplo si tu
sueldo es inferior a seis mil euros al
año no pagas ningún impuesto la franja
que va de los seis mil a los veinticinco
mil 200 euros tiene tipo reducido a
partir de los 25 mil 200 euros todo el
mundo paga exactamente lo mismo y no
existe ningún tipo de beneficio fiscal
en otras palabras que no solamente es un
impuesto simple sino que también es
neutral y diréis que significa neutral
pues que es un impuesto pensado
únicamente para recaudar y diréis un
momento es que los impuestos sirven para
otra cosa que no sea recaudar dinero
para las arcas del estado pues por
supuesto que si en muchos otros países
como españa los impuestos premian o
castigan distintas decisiones por
ejemplo para los que veáis este vídeo
desde cataluña si invertirse en empresas
en expansión que cotizan en el mercado
alternativo bursátil podéis deducir os
hasta diez mil euros en vuestra
declaración
pensadlo bien esta medida está
incentivando un tipo de inversión sobre
otro tipo de inversión es decir que
podría darse el caso de que una persona
invirtiera en la empresa
antes que la empresa ve solo por
cuestiones fiscales en este caso
hablamos de unos impuestos muy pocos
neutrales en estonia sin embargo
hacienda no intenta promocionar ninguna
empresa ni ningún tipo de inversión en
concreto y esto tiene una doble ventaja
no sólo es un sistema más justo sino que
también es mucho más sencillo tan
sencillo que hacer una declaración de la
renta en este país lleva sólo cinco
minutos y creedme esto no es ninguna
exageración
[Música]
las imágenes que estáis viendo son de un
tutorial del gobierno de estonia sobre
cómo hacer la declaración de la renta
tenéis el enlace completo del vídeo en
la descripción y literalmente hablamos
de un proceso que se puede hacer en 5
minutos y 13 segundos pero sin duda
alguna la super ventaja estonia está en
su impuesto de sociedades- un tipo del
20 por ciento y diréis es un impuesto
abajo pues no exactamente en españa está
entre un 20 y un 25 por ciento
dependiendo del tamaño de la empresa
pero la super ventaja estonia está en
cómo se paga ese impuesto de entrada
solo tributamos cuando sacamos el dinero
de la empresa es decir que si
reinvertimos los beneficios no pagamos
ni un duro además no hay impuestos por
dividendos con lo que se evita la doble
tributación y por encima de todo las
empresas estonias pueden compensar las
pérdidas de años anteriores con las
ganancias de otros años y de nuevo tanto
pagar impuestos como crear una sociedad
en este país es tan sencillo como
hacerse una cuenta de facebook y esto no
es una metáfora
las imágenes que estáis viendo son de
otro tutorial sobre cómo crear empresas
en estonia literalmente bastan tres
minutos para hacerlo y diréis vale venga
todo esto suena fantástico impuestos
simples neutrales vengan dónde está la
trampa que han sacrificado los estonios
para tener unos impuestos tan
competitivos pues ahora mismo no vamos a
ver
una estrategia de la burocracia pero la
respuesta es no estonia no ha tenido que
sacrificar su estado del bienestar
tienen salud pública educación públicas
carreteras y transporte público es más
el transporte público es gratuito para
los ciudadanos
por supuesto lo pagan en forma de
impuestos pero tú puedes ir por las
calles de cualquier ciudad de estonia y
montarte en el tranvía sin pagar un solo
euro su sistema educativo está entre los
mejores del mundo y todo esto con una
deuda pública del 84 por ciento del
primero
y ya sé lo que se estará preguntando
alguno vale y dónde está la trampa de
dónde sacan el dinero en estonia qué
pasa que crece de los árboles la
respuesta es la eficiencia es decir
conseguir el mismo resultado con menos
recursos recordáis que os decía que en
el año 2009 estonia despidió al 40% de
su plantilla pues ese fue el principio
de toda una revolución una de esas
revoluciones silenciosas de las que rara
vez se habla en los medios pero que
deberíamos tener muy en cuenta
en el año 2013 se aprobó la nueva ley de
servicio público
esta ley decía cosas tan revolucionarias
como que a partir de ese momento la
política de contratación estaría
descentralizada es decir que no es el
gobierno en tallinn quien decide quién
se contrata o a quien se despide es esa
oficina de hacienda pequeñita en un
pueblecito perdido en los bosques
estonios la que él decide si pueden
prescindir de un trabajador o si
necesitan contratar a otro sin embargo
aunque las contrataciones sean tan
descentralizada hay un objetivo impuesto
desde el estado un objetivo a largo
plazo lograr que los funcionarios no
superen el 12 por ciento de la población
activa y para eso quieren un principio
burocracia cero y cómo se reduce la
burocracia pues de muchas formas en el
año 2015 el gobierno hizo dos encuestas
una a los empresarios del país y otra a
los propios funcionan
[Música]
en esa encuesta pedían sugerencias sobre
cómo aligerar los trámites burocráticos
es decir que los propios funcionarios
estuvieron ayudando a reducir el peso de
la administración gracias a esta
encuesta
estonia se dio cuenta de que por ejemplo
las distintas agencias del gobierno
usaban 14 softwares distintos de
contabilidad obviamente esto generaba un
montón de duplicidades e ineficiencias y
así es como se pusieron de acuerdo y
eligieron un único software o algo
parecido se ha hecho con el uso de la
información toda la información fiscal
de los ciudadanos está centralizada en
un único sistema que se llama ex rom ex
road conecta a todas las agencias del
gobierno pero también a los bancos
comerciales ya toda clase de entidades
financieras que quieran conectarse
y de esta forma la detección del fraude
fiscal es mucho más efectiva los bancos
comparten la información fiscal de sus
clientes con el gobierno y lo hacen en
tiempo real gracias a eso el 95% de las
declaraciones se hacen online con
sistemas tan sencillos como el que hemos
visto antes y en lugar de necesitar a
miles de personas procesando facturas o
investigando fraudes el mismo trabajo se
hace con mucha menos plantilla
pero esperad un momento porque esto no
lo es todo ya sé lo que pensáis mucho
sobre todo si trabajáis como
funcionarios todo esto está muy bien
pero realmente esperas que todos los
funcionarios se dediquen a aprender
nuevos programas de software y nuevos
métodos súper innovadores y 2.0 cada año
aquí es donde entra el programa de
formación continua gracias a todas esas
encuestas que os he dicho antes estonia
se dio cuenta de que basta con formar a
los cargos intermedios para cambiar toda
la administración
los cargos intermedios son el nexo entre
los directores y los trabajadores de
base así que gracias a todos estos
programas
estonia no ha dejado de reducir los
recursos que emplea para dar los mismos
servicios públicos para que os hagáis
una idea solo entra el año 2015 y 2017
estonia redujo su plantilla pública en
2.300 trabajadores tal vez no os
parezcan números muy grandes pero es que
hablamos de un país de un millón de
habitantes para que os hagáis una idea
toda la administración estonia consta de
116 mil funcionarios
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
es que ya me puedo imaginar lo que me
pondréis un montón de gente en los
comentarios pues menuda solución
despedir a funcionarios a nadie le gusta
que le despidan y ahí es donde entran
las ventajas de tener una economía tan
dinámica el paro en estonia no llega ni
al 6% es decir que es realmente sencillo
encontrar otro trabajo de hecho es
bastante normal que una persona deje una
empresa privada para entrar en una
pública y viceversa por supuesto que
todo este sistema no es perfecto y esto
ya tiene muchos desafíos por delante
principalmente el de integrar a su
minoría rusa o la brecha salarial entre
géneros que sigue siendo una de las más
altas de europa
ahora bien objetivamente es un modelo de
país que deberíamos tener en cuenta han
demostrado que con buenas políticas es
compatible tener un estado del bienestar
con impuestos bajos y crecimiento
económico
[Música]
y eso en cuanto a igualdad de ingresos
se refiere estonia es más igualitario
que muchos países con impuestos más
altos como españa italia o reina
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros es que se podrían importar
algunas cosas del modelo estonio en
vuestro país si os ocurre algún aspecto
concreto en el que se podría mejorar la
administración en vuestro país podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto